WOJTEK KALICINSKI: Hi, my
name is Wojtek Kalicinski,
and this is Android
Tool Time, with What's
New in Android Studio 2.3.
After the feature-packed
release that was 2.2,
we are starting the new year
with Android Studio 2.3, which
offers many refinements and
fixes to existing components,
as well as some
exciting new features.
The first thing
I'd like to mention
is the overhaul of
the Instant Run UI.
We followed advice
from developers,
and now provide two buttons--
Run, which you will
use to deploy and start
your app, and Apply Changes,
for any subsequent code
and resource modifications.
This uses Instant Run to quickly
update the running app using
cold, warm, or hot swap, and now
requires a device or emulator
running Lollipop and above.
In case you happen to see
any unexpected problems,
you can always use
the Run button again
to force a full app restart.
Speaking about speeding
up build times,
in Android Gradle
plug-in 2.3, we've
now enabled the build
cache by default.
The build cache is a shared
directory on your machine
where libraries are
extracted and compiled
to be used across all projects,
making both incremental
and full builds faster.
We've also made some general
performance improvements
in product sync and
the Gradle integration
in this version
of Android Studio,
and moved to Gradle version 3.3.
The ID itself brings the new
features of the IntelliJ 2016.2
release, such as the
new Inspections Tool
window, overhauled
notifications, breadcrumbs
in the Java editor, and more.
The Layout Editor
received some updates too.
In the Palette
window, we now show
widget previews and support
sorting and filtering by name.
The property inspector,
here on the right,
now lets you add the
most-used properties
to your favorites for quick
access on the Overview page.
And finally, the visual
editor has a new set
of controls and refined visuals
for constraint layout editing,
including new
icons, an easier way
of adding baseline handles, and
support for two big features
of the constraint layout--
chains and ratios.
By the way, constraint
layout is now
the default when creating new
projects with Android Studio
templates.
Moving on, the vector
drawable import dialog
received a small but
highly requested upgrade.
You can now search the
material icons catalog
by name, which makes
it a lot easier
to locate the one you need.
For raster images, we've
added WebP support in the ID.
WebP is an image compression
format developed at Google
that can replace both JPEG and
PNG images with smaller file
sizes and similar quality.
You can now convert images
to WebP straight from the IDE
by right-clicking
on a file or folder
and selecting Convert to WebP.
Since WebP support varies
across Android versions,
we've also added
Lint checks that
look at the content
of your images
and will warn you if they're
not compatible with the min SDK
version in your project.
Next up, we have the
app links assistant.
It guides you
through the process
of adding app links support
to your app, which includes
creating intent
filters for URLs,
modifying activity code
to handle those intents,
and generating a digital asset
links file for your website.
For fans of Lint, we have some
new and updated Lint checks.
We now support
additional annotations
such as restrict to and
visible for testing,
and the Lint report
HTML file now
has a material design look
with syntax highlighting.
The biggest addition, however,
is Lint baseline support,
which lets you save the current
set of known Lint errors
and ignore them
for future builds.
This gives you a way of
progressively dealing
with technical debt
in your project
while still having the
benefit of being informed
about any new
warnings and errors
that you might introduce.
In the SDK Tools, we've recently
added a command line interface
for the SDK manager
called SDK Manager.
You can use it to automate
installing or updating
SDK components, for example, in
scripts or on your CI server.
And lastly, the
Espresso Test Recorder
from previous Android
Studio versions
gained a few improvements
and is now considered stable.
So you can use it for
adding Espresso UI
tests to your applications.
Follow our account on Twitter
if you have any questions
about the new version, and
for the latest Android Studio
news and tips.
Thanks for watching, and for
more Android Studio videos,
click here.